NICOLA MARZARI: --for
all our applications
and for the lab sessions.
I guess I keep using
Albert Einstein.
This is the 100th anniversary of
his sort of famous year, 1905,
so just a little celebration.
One slide of a
reminder of what we
have seen in the
previous lecture,
we have really developed
the formalism leading
to the Hartree-Fock equations.
And the Hartree-Fock
equation follow
from a set of very simple
and very beautiful path.
We have the
Schrodinger equation,
and we have reformulated the
Schrodinger equation in terms
of the variational principle.
So we have a functional.
And we know that we can
throw into that functional
any arbitrary wave function,
and it'll give us an expectation
value of the energy.
And sort of the closer we get
to the true ground state wave
function, the lower that
energy is going to be.
We are never going to go
below the ground state energy.
And so it's sort of a
very powerful approach
to try out sorts of
possibilities and solution.
And in particular, sort
of Hartree and Fock
took this approach.
They wrote sort of the
most general many-body wave
function that can be written
as a product of single particle
orbitals.
That was actually the
original Hartree solution.
Wave functions
written as data do not
satisfy a fundamental symmetry
of interacting fermions.
That is they are
not anti-symmetric.
And so what you do?
You take this product of
single particle orbitals,
and you sum it with all
the possible permutation,
with all the possible
signs in front,
so that the overall wave
function is anti-symmetric.
And that can be sort
of written compactly
as what is called as
later determinant here.
And basically, now our unknowns
are the n orbitals phi.
And so we need to determine the
shape of this n single particle
orbitals.
And we want to
determine them such
that they minimize
the expectation value
of the variational principle.
And so that leads basically to
a set of differential equation
is just functional analysis.
And when you ask yourself
what are the conditions
that those single
particle orbitals need
to satisfy in order to minimize
the variational principle,
well, this is it, the
Hartree-Fock equation.
So each single particle
orbital phi of lambda
need to satisfy basically a
Schrodinger-like equation.
Again, as always, there is
a kinetic energy term here.
There is the interaction
with the external potential
that is just the
potential of the nuclei.
And then come the
so-called mean field terms.
So the electron lambda
here will interact
with each and every
other electron
mu via an electrostatic
interaction.
You see phi star times phi
is the charge density coming
from the orbital mu.
And the field that the
electron lambda fills
is the electrostatic
average density.
And in these, we sum
over all the electrons
including the electron lambda.
So up to now, we have a system
that is self-interacting.
An electron lambda fills the
electrostatic interaction
with itself.
That, in principle,
is not correct.
But luckily, this next term
that is called the exchange term
cancels that exactly.
And the exchange term is
the direct consequence
of having written the trial
wave function not just
as a product of a
single particle orbital,
because up to now
we would have sort
of something closer to
the Hartree equation,
but written as a proper
anti-symmetric wave
function, summing on all
the permutation with them
appropriate signs.
And so, basically, we have
Schrodinger-like equation.
A great advantage with respect
to the Hartree equation
is now the operator doesn't
change depending on the index
lambda because this sums
if you want to go over all
the electrons including lambda.
So our only constraint
here is that we
need to find the n
lowest Eigen state
of this single
differential equation.
So if we have n
electrons, if you want,
it's not that we have n
different differential
equation, like it was the
case of the Hartree equation.
But we have an identical
differential equation
that is written here.
And we need to find the
n lowest energy states.
And those will be our
single-particle orbitals.
In all of this, we have started
from a variational principle.
So it's very easy to go
beyond the Hartree-Fock.
We can say, in large
r variational cluster,
we can add more
Slater determinants
with sort of different
coefficients.
We can try to construct a
more complex wave function.
And that solution will
become better and better.
Or we can sort of use
the perturbation theory.
And so quantum
chemistry has developed
a number of techniques that are
post-Hartree-Fock techniques
that become systematically
more and more accurate.
They are also more
and more expensive.
And that's if you want, the main
limitation of that direction.
What we'll see
today is something,
as they say in Monty Python,
completely different.
And that will be sort of
density functional theory.
That's, if you
want a theory that
starts from a very different set
of hypotheses, the net result
will be, again, a set of
single-particle equations.
The concept are very
similar actually, formally,
to the Hartree-Fock
equation, but they
have been derived in a
completely different spirit.
Density functional
theory tends to be
less expensive than
Hartree-Fock and, overall,
tends to be more accurate.
Especially for solid,
it's much more accurate.
You'll see when we discuss
case studies the Hartree-Fock
solution for, say,
interacting electron gas
or in general for
metals tends to make
them semiconducting
or insulating-like.
So Hartree-Fock then works
very poorly for solids.
And that's why, if you want
density functional theory,
comes from the solid
state community,
while Hartree-Fock that tends
to work very well for atoms
comes from the quantum
chemistry community.
And all the theory was developed
by Walter Kohn, and coworkers.
So you'll see the
Hohenberg and Kohn
theorem, the Kohn [INAUDIBLE]
mapping during the '60s.
But I would say it's
only during the '70s
that people started to
be able to actually solve
interesting cases using
density functional theory.
And it's really the
beginning of the '80s--
you'll see some
cases here today--
in which people started
calculating something that had
sort of a direct application.
So we'll see the phrase
diagram of silicon
as a function of
pressure or volume
and sort of the first principle
prediction of properties
of solids.
Walter Kohn, for the development
of this eventual theory,
got the Nobel Prize
for chemistry in 1998
together with John Pople.
That has been the person
that's been fundamental
in the development
of Hartree-Fock
and post-Hartree-Fock
approaches in quantum chemistry.
OK.
So let's see sort of what is
the general idea behind density
functional theory.
And in many ways,
we'll sort of start
from ideas that
had been developed
at the end of the '20s and the
beginning of the '30s, what
is nowadays called the
Thomas-Fermi approach.
And again, the
basic idea here is
that the wave function of a
many-body interacting problem
is an object that is
too complex to treat.
And it would be very, very
nice if we could instead try
to deal with a simple object.
And sort of one of the choices
could be the charge density.
So if you want, Thomas
and Fermi independently
were asking themselves,
well, could we
try to solve not
really a Schrodinger
equation in the
many-body wave function,
but solve something else in
which our only unknown is
the charge density?
If you think for a
moment, the charge density
is one of the sort of
fundamental variables
in the description of our
interacting electron problem.
And so this was the question.
Can we do something just
with the charge density?
And so what they
did is writing out
what we would call a
heuristic function.
That is trying to devise a set
of terms that would give us
the energy of a set of
electrons in a potential
just as a functional of
their charge density.
And so, by now,
you could sort of
think that some of
the relevant terms
will be electron-electron
interactions, electron
interaction.
And we could write a sort
of electrostatic term,
like the Hartree term in
the Hartree or Hartree-Fock
equation, that is just a
functional of the charge
density.
So this is sort of fairly easy.
It's also very easy
to sort of imagine
what could be the
interaction of the electrons
with an external potential
through the charge density.
It will be just the integral
of that external potential
times the charge density.
What becomes really
critical is finding
a functional that will give
us the quantum kinetic energy.
If you think, in the
Schrodinger equation,
the quantum kinetic energy is
really the second derivative
of the wave function.
And obtaining from
a charge density
only some insight
into what could
be the second derivative of the
wave function is very complex.
If you think for a moment at the
extreme case of a plane wave,
OK, so a sine and cosine sort
of in space, if you remember,
the charge density given by
a plane wave is a constant.
We just multiply the
imaginary exponential
times its complex conjugate.
That gives us a constant.
So all plane waves
lead to a constant,
but obviously the quantum
kinetic energy of a plane wave
depends on the wavelength
of that plane wave
because the second
derivative is what counts.
So what I'm trying
to say is that, when
we look at this as a possible
wave function, a function,
say, of r and the charge
density that comes from this
is going to be a constant,
this wave function
times this complex conjugate.
But the kinetic
energy of this object
is going to be
minus 1/2 k square--
sorry, plus 1/2 k square.
And so there is
really not a good way
for this extreme case
to correlate its charge
density to its kinetic energy.
It's an ill-defined problem.
And this is really
the difficulty.
So there isn't really
a good way if you
wanted to extract
the information
on the second derivative
from just the charge density.
Now, [INAUDIBLE] sort
of this objection,
they tried to find a
reasonable functional, so
without sort of trying to
get the exact solution,
but try to find a reasonable
function that would give us
a good estimate to the quantum
kinetic energy starting
from the charge density.
And the solution to
this problem that
is something very
important is what
we could call a local
density approximation.
So the problem here is that we
have a non-homogeneous charge
density everywhere in space.
And we try to figure
out what could
be the quantum kinetic energy
of this non-homogeneous problem.
And the approximation
that Thomas and Fermi did
was, well, dividing this
non-homogeneous problem
in a set of infinitesimal
volume in space.
So it's a bit difficult
to draw, but suppose
you have the charge
density coming
from some atom or some molecule.
This is a non-homogeneous
charge density distribution.
Now, what you do is you
divide this in space
and set a very small
infinitesimal, if you want,
volume.
And inside each volume,
the charge density
can be approximated
as a constant.
And what Thomas
and Fermi said is,
well, the contribution coming
from this infinitesimal volume,
say, the first one to the
overall quantum kinetic energy
will be given by that volume
times the kinetic energy
density of the homogeneous
electron gas at that density.
So if, again, we
partition all space,
we could have that the density
in this little cube is 0.5.
Here is 0.6.
Here is 0.7.
Outside, it goes to 0.
But we can actually calculate
in some other way what
would be the quantum
kinetic energy
of a homogeneous electron gas.
That's a problem
that we can solve
if the homogeneous electron
gas is not interacting.
And we can solve it numerically
even if it is interacting.
So we can know what is
the quantum kinetic energy
of a homogeneous gas
with density 0.5,
density 0.6, density 0.7.
And so we can also
know what would
be the quantum kinetic energy
per unit of volume of data.
And so we'll say that this
non-homogeneous system in blue
will have an overall quantum
kinetic energy that is given
really by the integral
across space--
and it's written here--
of the quantum kinetic energy
of the homogeneous electron gas
integrated over space.
And, say, for the
non-interacting electron gas,
it's actually very easy to do.
So if you have a non-interacting
electron gas at a density rho,
its quantum kinetic energy
is just the rho to the 2/3
that then integrated
times the unit volume
gives us rho to the 5/3.
So by integrating this quantity,
we would get an approximation.
This approximation
is basically exact
in the limit of our
homogeneous system, obviously.
And it will be
sort of quite good
in the limit of our
non-homogeneous system that
has a very slowly
changing charge density.
The more, if you
want, inhomogeneous
your system becomes, the less
accurate this approximation is.
And of course, something
like an atom or a molecule
is a very inhomogeneous system.
You go with a
charge density that
goes from 0 to very high
volumes close to the core
of the nuclei.
So this is basically
the overall answer
for the overall expression
that Thomas and Fermi
postulated for the energy
of an inhomogeneous system.
They were saying,
well, suppose that we
have a system that has a certain
distribution of charge rho.
Without trying to solve the
Schrodinger equation finding
out the wave function and sort
of go through that the very
complex many-body route, we
can actually sort of postulate
that the energy could
be written, again,
as an electrostatic energy.
You see sort of each
infinitesimal volume
interacting with each
other infinitesimal volume
times via 1 over R
electrostatic interaction.
Then we have got an
external potential.
Again, it's usually the
Coulombic field of the nuclei.
And so the interaction
between the electron
and that external potential
is just trivial given by rho
times v.
And the difficult term,
the quantum kinetic energy,
has been calculated with a
local density approximation.
And this is the term that's
not going to be very good,
again, because it's very
difficult to figure out
what could be the curvature
of our wave function
just from the density that
that wave function produces.
But anyhow, this is a very
simple expression to deal with.
So for any external
potential v, we
can try to find out the rho
that minimizes this expression.
And this will be our
Thomas-Fermi solution.
There are obviously
a number of problems.
I'll show you in a
moment an example of what
the Thomas-Fermi solution
would give to an atom.
First of all, I
mean, there is really
no theoretical basis to this.
It's what we call a
heuristic derivation.
Thomas and Fermi
just wrote out what
could be a reasonable
energy functional,
and then tried to sort of see
what results it would give.
But there hasn't been any
kind of formal derivation
of that functional.
It's not like the Hartree-Fock
equation that sort of derive
just with some analysis from
the variational principle.
Another problem is that,
again, it doesn't really
sort of introduce the concept
of anti-symmetry that fermions
need to have, the fact that the
many-body wave function needs
to be anti-symmetric
upon exchange.
But you know, there is
no conceptual problem
in adding an exchange energy
to the previous functional.
Using the same
concept, the same idea
of local density
approximation, suppose that we
want to add an exchange term.
Well, we could look at what
is the exchange energy coming
from the Hartree-Fock
equation, say,
for a homogeneous electron gas.
And that gives us
rho to the 1/3 term.
And that's basically the
exchange energy density.
And so for an
inhomogeneous system,
we are going to sort of
approximate its overall
exchange energy just by taking
the integral of that energy
density that is 1/3 times
the sort of local value
of the charge density.
And so we have a rho to the 4/3.
And so, again, it's a local
density approximation.
The great consequence of
having this energy functional
that depends only
on r is that it
is absolutely inexpensive
from the computational point
of view.
The only variable that we
need to be concerned with
is just the a scalar as a
function of three coordinates.
That is the density
as a function of rho.
And it's what we call a
linear scaling system.
If you double the
size of your system,
the computational complexity
just becomes double.
So it has a lot of
very good things,
but it's got a
fundamental defect.
Because of that approximation
in the kinetic energy,
it actually does a very
poor job in describing
a non-homogeneous system.
So it would work reasonably
well for something like a metal.
Suppose that you want
to describe sodium,
or suppose you want
to describe aluminum.
Those are system in which
the valence electron produce
a charge density that
is very homogeneous.
So a Thomas-Fermi approach
could actually work well.
And it's actually been used
even very recently sort
of quite successfully
to describe problems
like the surfaces of lithium,
the surfaces of aluminum.
What happens, say, when
these simple metals melt?
What happens to the
sort of formation
of defects in aluminum?
So there are a
number of successes.
But sort of clear example
of what goes wrong
is, say, if we study an
inhomogeneous systems
like the argon atom.
And again, if we think at the
charge density of the argon
atom as a function, say,
of the radial distance
from the center
from the nucleus,
well, it will look
something like this.
We have first 1s, and then we
have the 2s, and the 2p shells.
This is somewhat
a poor depiction
of that charge density.
If we try to solve
the argon atom
with a Thomas-Fermi
approach, all these sort
of fine structure of the
core shells in the atoms
is completely washed out.
OK.
So it gives you a reasonable
approximation and sort
of an appropriate decay
of the charge density
as we move far away, but
a lot of those details
have completely disappeared.
And for this reason really
the Thomas-Fermi approach
wasn't developed
beyond the '30s apart
from some of these
recent applications
for the very specific
case of solids
that have a very
homogeneous charge density.
The reason why we
describe it here
is that because,
in many ways, it's
the grandfather
of the ideas that
were developed in the '60s
in density functional theory
and, in particular, the
idea that for a moment
that we should focus not
on the wave function,
but on the charge density of the
system as the key ingredient.
The great difference between
the Thomas-Fermi approach
and density functional theory is
that density functional theory
actually is a theory.
It starts with some
theorems that are proven.
And then it shows what are
the form of the equations
that, say, a charge density
need to satisfy in order
to solve exactly the problem.
So in many way, density
functional theory
is, in principle at
least, an exact theory.
It's sort of writes out what
are the equation that the charge
density needs to satisfy.
And those are absolutely
equivalent to a Schrodinger
equation for the wave function.
There are some difficulties.
And this is what we are going
to sort of go into right now.
But let me first give you
the conceptual framework
of density functional theory
and how it was derived.
And as usual, we start from
the Schrodinger equation.
OK.
So we start from the idea
that, in quantum mechanics,
for any given
external potential,
you have a well-defined
differential equation.
OK.
It's sort of very complex.
It describes a
many-body wave function.
So in most practical cases, we
might not be able to solve it,
but everything is well-defined.
You have an external potential.
You have the
differential equation
that the many-body wave
function needs to satisfy.
And so, in principle,
you have the solution.
And so in that sense, sort
of the first statement
here is summarized.
For a given external potential
and knowing how many electrons
are going to fill
this potential,
our quantum problem is
formally completely defined.
In principle, the
solution exists unique.
We might not be able to
calculate it, but it exists.
And once we know the many-body
wave function, that solution,
we know everything about
our quantum system.
OK.
So this is, if you want, the
trivial part of the conclusion.
That is, given an
external potential,
we find, by the Schrodinger
equation, the wave function.
The wave function determine all
the properties of our system
and, in particular, determine
the ground state charge
density.
So there is a
unique pathway that
starts from the
external potential
and leads us to the charge
density, the ground state
charge density.
Once you have defined
the potential,
you, in principle,
have uniquely defined
what is the ground state's
charge density of your system.
And so in that sense, we say
that the ground state charge
density, the ground state
energy, and all the properties
of our system are,
in some complex way,
a functional of our
external potential
and the number of electrons.
Functional, again,
can be anything.
And in this case, it goes
through the Schrodinger
equation, nothing sort
of complex at this point.
The sort of remarkable result
that no one had sort of figured
out between 1964 and 1965
is that the opposite is also
true and is not trivial at all.
So what Hohenberg and Kohn
stated first, actually,
in 1964, was this, that
the ground state charge
density is a
fundamental quantity,
as fundamental as the
external potential.
And in particular, not only
the external potential,
the terms uniquely the
ground state's charge density
of your system, but also
the vice versa is true.
That is, given a ground
state charge density,
in principle, one
can prove that there
is a unique external potential
for which that ground state's
charge density is the
ground state solution
for that external potential.
So if you have the
external potential,
conceptually it's trivial to
go through the Schrodinger
equation and its solution
to the charge density.
What Hohenberg and
Kohn are telling us--
and I'll just show you a sketch
of the proof in a moment--
is that in principle, if someone
is giving you a chance density
and is telling you
this charge density
is the ground state's
charge density
of a number of
electrons and electrons
in an external
potential, in principle,
what is that external potential
is an information that
is completely contained
into the charged density.
And it's not contained
in a trivial way.
It's not that you can look at
the ground state charge density
and guess what the
external potentially is.
And that's where all the
complexity of practical densely
functional theory comes.
But from the conceptual and
mathematical point of view,
these two quantities are
absolutely equivalent.
From one, you get the
other and vice versa.
And this sort of vice
versa was not trivial.
And that is sort of
what is contained
in the so-called first
Hohenberg and Kohn problem.
I won't go through
the derivation.
It's actually very simple.
I've printed it here in case
you sort of want to read it.
But it's basically is a
derivation ad absurdum.
What they are saying
there is that,
if that external
potential were not unique,
if there were two
external potential that
were different and would give
the same ground state energy,
we would get to absurdum.
So typical mathematical
demonstration,
we suppose that there are two
different external potential
that give the same
ground states as density
and we show that we arrive
to a conclusion that
doesn't make sense.
So there can be only a
single external potential.
And that's the proof.
And again, it wasn't trivial.
I mean, if you want, this
is a very basic statement.
But it took 40 years
to be formulated.
And it's actually not
true in other cases
that to first glance
look very similar.
Suppose that for a moment we
want to discuss excited states.
You could say, well, if
I have a charge density
and I say this is the
charge density of an excited
electronic state,
maybe I could also
recover the potential
that has generated there.
And that's not true, actually.
So there are sort
of a number of cases
in which this is not true.
But for this fundamental sort
of relation between the charge
density of the ground state
and the external potential,
this is true.
So we have sort of moved
away now our attention.
It's not any more
the many-body wave
function that we want to focus,
but is the charge density.
The charge density is as
much a fundamental variable
of our problem.
It's not a derived variable.
It's not something that
comes from the wave function,
but is something
that we can actually
focus all our attention into.
And now, we need to find the
equivalent of the Schrodinger
equation for the
charged density.
This is what Schrodinger had
done in the '20s, in 1925.
He said, this is the equation
that quantum objects satisfy.
And I'll call it the
Schrodinger equation.
Now, Hohenberg
and Kohn has shown
that we don't need to think
in terms of the wave function.
We can think in terms
of the charge density
as being the fundamental
descriptor of our quantum
system.
What is left?
They need to show me that
there is an equivalent
of the Schrodinger equation.
That is we can write a
density equation that
is sort of what will give me
the ground state and sort of all
the properties of the system.
And that's really the second
Hohenberg and Kohn theorem.
That is really writing
out the equivalent concept
of the Schrodinger equation
for the charge density.
And now, sort of, it
becomes fairly conceptual.
OK.
So this is the procedure.
And all of this in
the next few slides
is still a conceptual procedure.
It will describe objects that
are well-defined in principle,
that are conceptually
well-defined,
but we still don't
have a clue on what
they look like in practice.
And all the sort of density
functional application
goes through a
procedure that we'll
see later on that is the
sort of [INAUDIBLE] mapping
that gives a hint of what
these objects look like.
But up to now, we are
going to introduce objects
that are well-defined
in principle,
but we don't know
how they look like.
And so that's why somehow
density functional theory
is a much less intuitive
theory than something
like Hartree-Fock.
OK.
So this is going towards the
second Hohenberg and Kohn
theorem, defining the
fundamental equation
for the charge density.
And this is the step.
For any charge density
rho, so someone gives you,
someone draws you, an
arbitrary charge density.
Well, we know that there
is an external potential
of which that charge
density is the ground state.
We don't know what
it is, honestly,
but we have proven that there
is a unique external potential.
OK.
So because there is a
unique external potential,
there is a many-body
Schrodinger equation
with that potential in there.
And there is a
wave function that
is going to be the
ground state wave
function of that many-body
Schrodinger equation.
So given a certain rho, we
know that an external potential
exists.
And it's unique.
It determines a
Schrodinger equation.
And that Schrodinger equation
determines our ground state
wave function that we call psi.
So what we are saying is that,
given a rho, in principle
that psi, the ground state wave
function of the Schrodinger
equation in the
external potential
that is uniquely
defined by the rho,
is also a well-defined object.
Again, we don't know what it
is, but it is well-defined.
And because it's a
well-defined object,
we can calculate the
expectation value
of that well-defined object
of the quantum kinetic energy
minus 1/2 sum over all i
of the second derivatives
and the electron-electron
interaction, just the 1
over ri minus rj term.
So again, this term is, in
principle, well-defined.
And we call this term the
universal density functional.
That is for any given
arbitrary rho, i, in principle,
can define a number that
is this number here.
I have the rho.
In principle, from the rho, I
have the external potential.
From the external potential, I
have the Schrodinger equation.
In principle, I'm able to solve
that Schrodinger equation found
in principle the many-body
ground state wave function.
That will be psi.
And I can calculate
the expectation value
of psi of the quantum
kinetic energy
and of the electron-electron
interaction term,
all well-defined.
We have really no clue on how
to calculate because we can't
really do in practice
any of the steps,
but this universal function of
the density is well-defined.
So with this
universal functional
that is now well-defined,
we can write out something.
We can write to an energy for
any given external potential
and for any given
charge density.
And we write it as this.
So for any given
charge density, there
will be a well-defined number
that is this universal density
functional of beta rho prime.
And then we add
another term that
is just trivially the
integral of this v,
this external potential, times
the charge density rho prime.
So again, this new
expression that we written
is well-defined.
For any rho prime and for
any external potential,
we can calculate
trivially this term.
And in principle, we
know what this number is.
And this is, if you want,
1964, 1965, the reformulation
of quantum mechanics.
Because, now,
Hohenberg and Kohn are
able to prove that there
is a variational principle.
That is, for this
expression written here,
for this functional
of rho prime,
we can prove that
for any rho prime
that we can throw in the
overall numerical value
of this expression
is always going
to be either greater or equal
to the ground state energy
that we would obtain from
the Schrodinger equation
in the presence of this
external potential.
So now, we have a well-defined
density functional.
So if you have an
external potential,
the z over r of your atom,
you can try out now not
wave functions that
are very difficult,
but you can try
out charge density.
And the charged
density that gives you
the lowest expectation
value, the lowest
value for this functional, will
be the ground state, the charge
density.
Small problem, we
have no clue what
this looks like as a
function of rho prime.
But if we knew, we would have
a wonderfully simple approach
to quantum mechanics.
Now, we don't need to deal
with the many-body complexity.
We just minimize this expression
as a function of rho prime.
And again, it's
sort of fairly easy
to prove this
variational principle.
But one needs probably to sit--
I've given you some reading.
So you're welcome, if you are
really interested in this,
to go back and read the first
Hohenberg and Kohn theorem
and read the second
Hohenberg and Kohn theorem.
But in many ways, the proof
of this second Hohenberg
and Kohn theorem
can be done again
through the
variational principle.
That is, if we have
a certain rho prime,
well, that, again, uniquely
determines the ground state
wave function.
Rho prime will determine
an external potential
that, in principle, is
different from this.
But rho prime will determine
an external potential
and will determine
our wave function
that is the solution of the
many-body Schrodinger equation.
And if we take the expectation
value of our Hamiltonian
with this external
potential in this,
but evaluated on the
wave function of c prime
that comes from this
charge density rho prime,
well, we can show that
this expectation value here
is just identical to functional
that I have just written.
And for the
variational principle,
then it needs to be
greater or equal than E0.
I won't sort of dwell into that.
And again, you can look at the
sort of detailed description
and in sort of some of the
many references that I've given
or that I've also
posted on the website.
But what is
conceptually important
is that we have a new equation.
OK.
So 1964, '65, quantum
mechanics turned around.
We don't have to think at
many-body wave functions.
We can think just
at charge density.
And all would be well
apart from this detail,
that we don't know what
that functional f of rho is.
And so we have a
conceptual approach,
but we don't have a
practical approach
to solve the density functional
reformulation of quantum
mechanics.
And this is, if you
wanted, true to this day.
We don't know what is the
exact form of f of rho.
If we knew it, sort
of most of our sort
of quantum mechanical
computational problems
would be trivially solved.
Because solving that variational
principle in the charge density
would be most likely
a trivial thing to do.
The issue is that not
only we don't know,
but we have understood a
lot of what that exchange
correlation-- of what that
universal density functional
is.
And it's very complex.
So it's unlikely that there is
a simple analytical expression
of it as a function of
the charge density only.
But, you know, the other
great piece of, if you want,
quantum engineering
by Walter Kohn
was finding out a very
good approximation
to that density functional.
We don't know what
the exact one is.
But now, what they
are doing is, well,
finding out one that is going
to be very, very closely
similar to the exact one.
And so they are going to throw
in some physical intuition
to this problem that
up to now, if you want,
has been a mathematical problem.
It's another layer of
complexity in this discussion,
so I hope I'm not losing you.
But sort of what
Walter Kohn did--
I think he had a young postdoc
arriving from Cambridge.
Lu Sham had just done his PhD
in England and came there.
And sort of, you
know, he told him,
I have this new
variational principle.
Let's see what we can do to make
it into a practical solution.
I think they were in Santa
Barbara, in San Diego probably,
at that time.
OK.
So this is what they
are going to do.
Remember, sort of,
what is the problem.
We need to figure out what
is a reasonable approximation
to this functional here.
So what they say
is, well, suppose
that someone has given
us this charge density.
So we need, in
principle, to find out
what would be the many-body
wave function that
is solution of this external
potential that corresponds
to this charge density.
This is going to
be very complex.
Let's invent a problem
in which electrons do not
interact between each other.
OK.
So electrons-- so
that's the sort
of main problem in the
Schrodinger equation,
that electrons interacting
with each other
introduce the two-body
electrostatic repulsion
in the Schrodinger equation.
And that's what
makes it difficult.
Well, what Kohn and
Sham say is let's
for a moment suppose that
there is a system of electrons
that don't interact.
So the only thing that those
so-called Kohn and Sham
electrons fill is the
external potential.
OK.
So those Kohn and Sham
electrons will solve,
will satisfy, a Schrodinger
equation that is much simpler.
Because there is no
electron-electron interaction.
Those Kohn and Sham electron,
the only thing that they fill
is a new potential.
And they will have their
own quantum kinetic energy.
So what they are saying is, for
any given charge density rho,
there is going to be
a non-interacting set
of electrons who's ground
state charge density is
identical to rho.
So we have said, if we
have a charge density rho,
you can all go through, find
out the external potential that
comes from rho, the
Schrodinger equation,
the many-body interacting
electrons solution.
But now, what we
are going to say
is we can also think at a system
of non-interacting electrons.
And we want those
non-interacting electrons
to fill a potential that is
such that their ground state is
going to give us a
charge density that
is identical to the charge
density I'm dealing with.
OK.
And we call that
external potential
the Kohn-Sham potential.
OK.
So now, for a
charge density, you
don't only have to think
at all the complexity
that I've discussed up to now.
But you have also to think
that, for a charge density,
there is going to be
this set of Kohn and Sham
known interacting electrons.
And there is going to
be a potential that
is called the Kohn and
Sham potential that is such
that the ground state
of the Schrodinger
equation for non-interacting
electron, that
is without electron-electron
interaction, in that Kohn
and Sham potential will give
us a wave function and a ground
state that leads to a charge
density identical to the charge
density I'm sort
of dealing with.
OK.
What do we do with this?
Well, at this stage, there is
a sort of great simplification
that, for the
Schrodinger equation
of non-interacting
electron, we actually know
what is the exact solution.
So it's actually
very simple to solve
a Schrodinger equation in which
the electrons do not interact.
Because, now, this
later determinant
is actually the exact solution.
So if you have a set of
non-interacting electrons,
you don't have the
electron-electron term
in that Schrodinger equation,
this later determinant is not
only a good approximation,
but it's actually
the exact solution.
So for this non-interactive
set of electrons,
we can solve everything exactly.
And in particular, we
can calculate, say,
what is the kinetic
energy of this set
of non-interacting electrons.
OK.
So now, we can sort of have
a somehow pseudo-physical way
of decompose this
mysterious density
functional into different terms.
So what we are actually
doing via the Kohn and Sham
mapping is extracting from
here terms that are very large
and that we know how to write,
we know how to calculate.
And then, hopefully, once we
have extracted all these terms
that we know how to define,
we remain with something
that is very small
and that we'll
find another numerical
approximation for it.
So Kohn and Sham say, well, we
have this well-defined density
functional.
We extract two terms
that are well-defined.
And these two terms that's
sort of the great achievement
actually contain most of
the physics of our problem.
And the sort of small
term that is left over,
we are going to approximate
in some simple way.
And actually, the
approximation that they found
worked very well.
And that's why some of
this functional theory
became a practical theory.
And so in this sort
of density functional,
the first physical large
term that they extract
is the quantum
kinetic energy that we
call Ts not of the real system.
Because, again, even
if it's well-defined,
we don't know how to do that.
But what they were able to write
is the quantum kinetic energy
of this non-interacting problem.
So for a given
charge density, there
is this set of Kohn and Sham
non-interacting electrons
that lives in a potential, such
that they have the same ground
state charge density.
And their kinetic
energy is trivial
because it's going to be
just the kinetic energy
of this later determinant, just
the sum of a single particle
term.
So for a charged
density now, there
is a well-defined
quantum kinetic energy
that is not the true quantum
kinetic energy of the system,
but is the quantum
kinetic energy
of this sort of
associated system
of non-interacting electrons.
But this term is
now well-defined.
They say, well, let's
extract another term that
is well-defined that is just
a Hartree electrostatic energy
of a charge density
distribution.
OK.
So if we look at the charge
density distribution in which
each infinitesimal
volume interacts
with each other
infinitesimal volume
with an electrostatic
interaction,
that's going to be the term.
And you know, what we
are left is now something
that they call the
exchange correlation term.
That is everything else.
OK.
So F, in principle,
is an exact quantity.
We are now able to define our
quantum kinetic energy term.
That is an exact quantity,
but is not really
the quantum kinetic
energy of the true system.
But we sort of
say, you know, this
is going to be equal
to a well-defined term
plus another well-defined
term plus a third term
that we don't know.
So we have sort of
decomposed a quantity
that we have no clue what it is
into three terms of which two
terms are well-defined.
And all our cluelessness is
contained in the third term.
And we call this third term
the exchange correlation,
but the sort of
physical advantage
of having done this
is that it turns out
that these two terms capture
a lot of the complexity
of your problem.
And this term tends
to be fairly small.
OK.
So that's all, actually.
That's why it works very
well because somehow they
manage to capture the
complexity of our system.
And so once that exchange
correlation term is defined
and it's approximated in some
way that we'll see in a moment,
our problem is now
well-defined because we really
have a variational principle.
Remember, the universal
density functional
plus the external
potential plus the charge
density in the field of
the external potential
minimizes the sort of
new variational principle
that comes from the
Hohenberg and Kohn theorem.
And so we can write it,
our variational principle.
That is this quantity
with the constraint
that the number of
electrons should be
equal to n should be minimum.
And as usual, when you sort of
write a variational principle,
you are saying that sort of the
differential of that quantity
needs to be equal to 0.
Or if you want, I mean,
this is a generic term.
You have a set of what are
called Euler-Lagrange equation,
basically.
That is nothing else than
differential analysis.
That is you are
asking yourself, what
are going to be
the conditions that
need to be satisfied
by the charge density
in order to satisfy the
variational principle?
There is always this sort
of 1 to 1 correspondence.
You have a
variational principle.
It gives you
differential equation.
Or you have
You can rewrite them in
a variational principle.
We have seen that for
the Schrodinger equation.
And we see this, in particular,
now explicitly for the Kohn
and Sham orbital.
So I'll actually go directly
to the explicit expression
of the Kohn and Sham orbitals.
Again, remember that
what we have done
is we have defined a
variational principle that
acts on a universal
density functional
F plus the charge density
and the external potential.
And we have decomposed,
we have extracted,
from this universal
functional sort of terms
that are large and physical.
And we have sort of pushed
all the many-body complexity
of the problem in something
that we call the exchange
correlation functional.
That is, again, a functional
of the charge density.
We don't know yet what that
function of the charge density
is.
But luckily, it's
going to be small.
So in a moment,
we'll approximate it.
And then we ask ourselves,
what are the differential
equations that derive from
this variational principle?
Well, in principle, I
had written them here.
OK.
We just need to take the
variation with respect
to the charge density
and imposing the Lagrange
multiplication constraint.
And so this would be basically
that the charge density needs
to satisfy this set of
equation, the sort of functional
derivative of this
non-interacting quantum
kinetic energy plus a
number of terms that
really contain the
external potential,
the Hartree interaction.
And the exchange
correlation need
to be equal to the
Lagrange multiplier that
fixes the number of electrons.
We are not able to calculate
this functional derivative
because, remember, the
quantum kinetic energy
of the non-interacting
system is again
written as a later determinant.
And so there is
sort of, you know,
this type of back in which, even
if we had written everything
in terms of a charge
density, we are not
able to explicitly
calculate not only
the derivative of the true
interacting electron's
kinetic energy with
respect to rho,
but we are not even able
to calculate the functional
derivative of the
non-interacting kinetic energy
with respect to rho.
But what we are able is actually
to calculate the derivative
of that non-interacting
kinetic energy with respect
to the orbitals that describe
the Kohn and Sham electrons.
Remember that these
non-independent Kohn and Sham
electrons have an exact solution
that is a later determinant.
And so we know there are trivial
many-body wave function is
a later determinant composed
by a single particle orbitals.
And the functional derivative
of that independent
non-interacting
electron's kinetic energy
with respect to the
single-particle orbital
is now trivial and is
just minus 1/2 del square.
So at the end of all these sort
of complex formulation, what
we are left with is
something very simple
and probably something you
should focus your attention
from now on.
We have now a set of
Kohn and Sham equation
that are the
differential equation
that the electrons need
to satisfy in order
to satisfy the variational
principle with the caveat
that, in this Kohn
and Sham equation,
there is at term, an
exchange correlation term,
that we still don't
know what it is.
It's sort the formally defined
as the functional derivative
of the exchange
correlation energy
with respect to
the charge density.
But we'll need to
approximate somewhere.
And what this equation
describes is not anymore
the true electrons
in your system,
but they describe this
cousins of the true electrons.
They describe this Kohn and
Sham non-interacting electrons
that have their
own orbital psi i.
And that will give us
a ground state charge
density that, if the exchange
correlation functional was
exact, would be not only this,
as obviously the same ground
state energy of our
interacting electron system,
but it would be the exact
solution of the problem.
OK.
So this equation look a lot
like a Schrodinger equation.
They look a lot, if you want,
like the Hartree-Fock equation
that we've written before.
Because what we are seeing
is that the a Kohn and Sham
electron i fills a quantum
kinetic energy operator,
fills a Hartree operator,
fills the external potential,
and then fills this
sort of remaining term
that is the exchange
correlation potential.
Again, if we knew what were
this exact exchange correlation
potential, we would have an
exact solution to the problem.
But we know a very
good approximation.
And then if you want
finding the ground state,
it's not very different
from finding the ground
state of the Hartree-Fock
equation with the caveat
that actually this
term here is going
to be much simpler
than the exchange term
of the Hartree-Fock equation.
If you go back to
the first slide
to the Hartree-Fock
equation, the last term
is that numerically
very complex expression
in which we sort of
take the orbital,
and we put it inside an
integral differential operator.
Now, it's become simpler.
And that's all if you want.
So the Kohn and Sham
equation look very similar.
In practice, they
are simpler to solve.
They tend to be more
accurate in most cases.
And that's, at the end,
what leads to the success.
But what is critical
for all of this
is having a reasonable
approximation to the exchange
correlation potential.
If we had the exact exchange
correlation potential,
everything would be exact
in this formulation.
We would find the Kohn and
Sham independent electrons
that were sort of the ground
state electrons for that charge
density that is ultimately
equal to the charge
density of the
interacting electrons
in this external potential.
OK.
And we have the Euler-Lagrange
or Kohn and Sham differential
equation in the previous page.
I written here sort of, you
know, just for reference
also what would be the
total energy of the system.
And usually, if you had
an independent electron,
the total energy of
the system is trivially
the sum of each of the
single particle energies.
OK.
If you have 10
electrons and they
don't interact with
each other, you
can calculate what is the energy
of each of these 10 electrons.
Sum all of them, and that's
the total energy of the system.
In this case, it's more complex.
And the total
energy of the system
can't be really written
as that, but it's
got other terms that depend
on the charge density.
That's sort of this
is, in summary, what
your total energy is.
And again, there's nothing
else than kinetic energy term
sort of a Hartree term
functional charge density,
this exchange
correlation functional,
and the interaction between
the external potential
and the charge density.
But this is actually
different from the sum
of the eigenvalues.
That would be the sum of the
expectation values of psi i
calculated on the
single-particle orbital where
T is, again, just the simple
quantum kinetic energy.
And the VKS is this
Kohn and Sham potential.
So if you want to calculate the
total energy of your system,
even if it's made of
independent electron,
you can't sum just a
single particle orbitals.
But you have to sort of
deal with this expression.
Nothing complex in this, it's
just sort of a caveat that
is relevant when you
want to sort of-- you
know, this is the reason
why we can't really
find out the equivalent
of the [INAUDIBLE]
theorems for Hartree-Fock.
This is why at the end these
single-particle energies
are ultimately not
physically meaningful.
They sort of don't give us
the total energy of the system
just by taking the
sum over all of them.
OK.
So in order to make this
into a practical algorithm,
the only part that remains
is finding an approximation
to that exchange correlation
term, to that last term.
Remember, we had sort of
defined this density functional.
We have been able to extract
two meaningful terms,
the Hartree electrostatic energy
and the non-interacting Kohn
and Sham kinetic energy.
And we have said what is left
is a function of the charge
density that we
call the exchange
correlation functional.
How we are going to
approximate that?
Well, we go back to
the Thomas-Fermi idea.
We are going to
do a local density
approximation to that exchange
correlation functional.
So again, what we
want to calculate
is the exchange correlation
energy for any arbitrary charge
density.
Sometimes I call the
charge density n.
charge density rho,
but they are always the same.
So how do we do this?
Well, we don't have
the full solution.
But what we can
say, again, is that,
for an inhomogeneous charge
density that changes values
and then drops to 0, I
can calculate the exchange
correlation energy for this
charge density distribution
by sort of decomposing it
in infinitesimal volumes.
Inside each
infinitesimal volume,
I can say the charge
density is constant.
And you see, I make a local
density approximation.
That is I say the contribution
to the overall exchange
correlation energy of
this inhomogeneous system
can be broken down.
And each infinitesimal volume
will give its own contribution
to the total exchange
correlation density.
You know, in principle,
it's not correct.
I mean, our problem doesn't
have to be local in any way.
Actually, as people say,
this exchange correlation
functional, the true
one, although we
don't know what it is, we
know that is ultra non-local.
So it can't be
decomposed into terms
that independently sum up.
So in principle,
we can't do this.
But in practice, it tends
to be a good approximation
for a lot of cases.
And so what is going to be the
contribution to the exchange
correlation energy from
this infinitesimal volume?
Let's say the charge
density there is 0.5.
Well, what we need
to do is we need
to find out what is the
exchange correlation
energy for the
homogeneous electron
gas that is at this density.
That's something that, with
some advanced computational
techniques, we can actually
find out almost exactly.
So we would know, if we had
a homogeneous charge density
0.5 everywhere, what
would be the charge
density per unit volume.
And we can find out what is
the exchange correlation charge
density per unit volume not only
for 0.5, 0.6, 0.7, anything.
And what we are saying is
that, in this non-homogeneous
problem, we construct the
overall exchange correlation
energy by summing up
these different pieces.
And so this is what Ceperley
and Alder did in 1980.
They basically found out what
was the almost exact sort
of closely to numerical
exact solution
for the homogeneous
electron gas.
That is for a system in
which you have only electrons
homogeneously, so the
charge density is identical
everywhere.
And those electrons interact.
So you can calculate the energy
of this interacting electron
problem exactly as a
function of the density.
OK.
So you change the density
in your sort of volume,
and you find out
what is this energy.
And then you can
calculate, for any
of this density, what is
the Kohn and Sham quantum
kinetic energy.
You can find out what is the
Hartree electrostatic energy.
And so you can also find
out, for this specific case
of the homogeneous
gas, numerically
what would be the exchange
correlation density.
And so that's
basically a function.
So for the homogeneous gas,
that is for the case in which n
doesn't depend on
r, people found out
what was basically this
exchange correlation energy.
It was calculated as a function.
This is a function of
what people call rs.
rs is the radius of a sphere
that contains one electron.
So it's a sort of
inverse quantity
with respect to the density.
So numerical calculation, what
are called quantum Monte Carlo
calculation, really solved
the interacting Schrodinger
equation problem.
But for the specific case
of an electron gas that
has a homogeneous
density, they were
able to do that for
various density.
And so, now, we have a function
for the homogeneous problem.
For the non-homogeneous
problem, we take a local density
approximation, and we say
that the overall exchange
correlation energy is given
by the integral over all
the infinitesimal volume.
And each infinitesimal volume
will have a certain density
and will contribute
with its own density.
If the density is going
to be equal to here,
this will be the value
of the contribution
of that infinitesimal volume.
If the density somewhere
else corresponds to this,
this will be the corresponding.
So we really match up this
overall exchange correlation
term from all the little
infinitesimal volume
exactly as
Thomas-Fermi had done,
but now we do it for a term
that is a much smaller term
in our problem.
Thomas and Fermi had done it
for the quantum kinetic energy.
Instead, what Kohn
and Sham do, they
do it for what is left from
the universal functional
once you have taken
out the electrostatic
and once you have taken out
the quantum kinetic energy
of the non-interacting
electrons.
At this point, if you
want 1980 and even
before without the
computation, with some sort
of analytical approximations
to this curve,
density functional theory
becomes not only a theory,
but also a practical algorithm.
We have a set of expression for
the exchange correlation term.
And so, now, it's just
a matter of trying
to find out what the solution
to these problems are.
And because somehow
conceptually we
start from the
homogeneous electron gas,
it turns out that this
approach worked especially well
for solids.
I mean, the valence
electrons in a solid
are much less structured than
the electrons in a molecule
that they need to drop to 0.
So the charge density
in a solid overall
varies less dramatically
as a function of space
than the electron density
in atoms and molecules.
And these are
actually sort of what
were summarized the numerical
result of Ceperley and Alder.
So they had calculated this
exchange correlation energy
as a function of the density.
And that was actually
a computational curve,
a set of dots.
And this is often cited,
again, per Perdew and Zunger
in a sort of paper of
theirs, among other things
sort of suggested the
analytical interpolation of all
the numerical data.
And so you see it's
something somehow exotic.
But while it's defined, this
is just not even a functional.
It's just a function
of the charge density.
So it's something
that is very simple
to calculate in practice.
And so at this point,
density functional theory,
is a well-defined theory.
So you see 1980, Ceperley and
Alder do this quantum Monte
Carlo calculation, find out
sort of what is this exchange
correlation energy.
Perdew and Zunger write
out a simple interpolation.
1982, sort of the
first time that I
think we see sort of where
all of this is going,
Marvin Cohen in Berkeley
sort of has been
working for two or three years.
Alex Zunger was there.
[INAUDIBLE] him, a
number of his students,
they have been able
to actually write out
all the electronic
structure codes
that are able to solve the
density functional equation
for the case of
a periodic solid.
And so they address
the case of silicon,
sort of the most important
material in electronics.
And so what they do
is they are able now
to calculate the
energy of that system
as a function of the atomic
position and, in particular,
as a function of the
lattice parameter.
So you know, first
thing that they do
is they take silicon in
its diamond structure,
so the FCC lattice with
two atoms as a basis.
And they calculate that
energy as a function
of the lattice parameter.
And it looks
something like this.
And then obviously, as
you have learned by now,
you look at what is the
minimum of that energy.
And that is the
theoretical prediction
of the lattice parameter.
And there is [INAUDIBLE],,
you know, 1% error.
They look at the
second derivative.
This curvature here is
really the bulk models
of your problem,
again, 5% 10% error.
And then they say, well, let's
suppose that we have silicon
not in the diamond
phase, but let's suppose
that we have silicon
in the beta tin phase.
And so this is also
experimentally known.
And we know in the beta
tin what is the lattice
parameter of silicon.
And we know from the
Maxwell construction
what is the pressure
at which we would
have a transition from,
say, diamond to beta tin.
And again, you know, I can't
remember what was the error,
but it's substantially correct.
And they were able to
actually sort of calculate
the sort of complex zoology
of all the high pressure
phases of silicon.
And it was in remarkable
agreement with the experiment.
So 1982, this is
[INAUDIBLE] and Cohen.
But in particular, Marvin Cohen
in Berkeley showed that for a--
Marvin Cohen.
For a realistic case,
density functional theory
is able really to give us
quantity of prediction.
Marvin Cohen has
actually become,
this year, the president of
the American Physical Society.
OK.
So this is really the beginning
of density functional theory
as a practical approach.
And in many ways, what has
happened between 1982 and today
is that we have become
better and better
at solving the algorithm
for this, overall, still
complex computational problem.
And you see a lot of this in
the next lecture that follows.
And we have become somewhat
better, not really dramatically
better, in calculating that
exchange correlation energy.
In a way, sort of the
ideas of Kohn and Sham
from 1965 of having a
local density approximation
is still very good.
I mean, it's not used
nowadays any more that much,
but it's as close as--
what we can do now is not
really that much better.
And as you can
imagine, sort of what
people have done
that was a bit better
was introducing gradients
in your problem.
So you're trying to
guess what the energy
of an inhomogeneous
system comes starting
from what you know about the
homogeneous electron gas.
Well, maybe you should somehow
throw in into your problem also
the first derivative of the
gradient of the density.
And so people did that fairly
soon in the early '80s.
And sort of using the gradients
was actually much worse.
There was a miracle in the
local density approximation
in which the actual expression
of the local density
approximation satisfies a
lot of symmetry properties
and scaling properties of what
would be the exact exchange
correlation functional.
At the time, people
put in gradients.
All these sort of symmetries
and scaling properties
were sort of thrown to the dogs.
And actually the GGAs--
sorry, the gradient
approximation,
were working much, much worse.
And so people need
to realize, sort of
in the late '80s, the work
of Axel Becke, of John Perdew
especially, a lot
of it, you sort of
need to introduce
gradients in ways
that still satisfy a lot
of these analytical forms.
And in many ways, by now,
there is a sort of generalized
exchange correlation functional
that's been sort of developed
in the mid-'90s by Perdew,
Kieron Burke now at Rutgers,
and Matthias Ernzerhof.
That is called the
PBE functional.
That has become sort
of the workhorse.
So a lot of the
time, you'll see sort
of density functional
calculation done
in the PBE, GGA approximation.
But again, these are
important improvements,
but if you want
just sort of very
little on top of
the local density
approximation of
the [INAUDIBLE]..
The chemistry community
has also sort of done
a number of very
intriguing developments.
In particular, there are
things that the Hartree-Fock
does very well.
In particular, because
you have the sort
of exchange term in
Hartree-Fock, you cancel,
remember, the
self-interaction say,
in the single-electron problem
coming from the Hartree,
the electrostatic problem.
Density functional
theory, in theory,
in its exact formulation, would
be self-interaction corrected.
But in practice, it is not.
If you solve the hydrogen atom
with density functional theory,
you have that the
electron interacts
with the charge density
created by the same,
by the electron itself.
And so what sort of the quantum
chemistry community has done
is, well, they said let's take
LDAs, let's actually take GGAs
that seem to work very well.
But let's actually construct an
exchange correlation functional
that has a little
bit of this, but it's
got also a little bit of
what we know worthwhile
in the Hartree-Fock equation.
So they construct
hybrid functional
which there are sort of
pure density financial terms
and the sort of Hartree-Fock
exchange term mixed in.
It makes the equation
much more complex.
And if you want, it's a sort
of less pure formulation
of density functional
theory, but it
can work reasonably well or
very well especially, again,
for atoms and molecules.
And this is where we are,
basically, with exchange
correlation functional.
I think I'll stop here for
today because that's actually
a lot of work.
What we'll start seeing
in the next class
is how we actually solve
this equation in practice.
On March 8th, you're going to
your second lab in which you
will actually study the
energy of a solid using
density functional theory.
What I said today
is probably the last
of the conceptual lectures.
And I understand that some
of it is very complex.
There is reading material
posted on the Stella website.
There is the
Kohanoff-Gidopoulos paper
on density functional theory.
And some of the readings that
I've given are very useful.
The two best books
that are also cited
at the end of this lecture
are probably the one
by [INAUDIBLE] or the
one by [INAUDIBLE]..
And they are both called Density
Functional Theory or Density
Functional Theory In Practice.
And they are cited
on the last page.
Otherwise, this is it for
today and see you next week.